statement about an incident in the
channel this morning
this is an ongoing search and rescue
incident but I can confirm that at the
time of making this statement tragically
there have been four fatalities
it would be inappropriate Mr Speaker for
me to go into further detail at this
time
there is a multi-agency response to this
terrible tragedy
his Majesty's Coast Guard the rnli
Southeast coast ambulance the ministry
of Defense police and Border Force
together with French vessels and a
commercial fishing vessels and
contractors at Western jet fall have
responded this morning Mr Speaker I have
spoken to borderforth officials based at
Dover manston and involved in the search
and rescue effort I've also spoken to my
French counterparts the interior
Minister Gerald Domin
a full statement will be provided to the
house in due course once the facts have
been fully established and the necessary
investigative work completed
I know that everyone in this house and
across the country will join me in
expressing our profound sadness and
deepest sympathies for everyone affected
by this terrible event
I know that they will also join me in
offering our profound gratitude to those
working on the search and rescue
operation
that very much includes those who are
responding to The Incident Commander Dan
omahani and his team are working
tirelessly with military colleagues and
other partners day in and day out
to try to prevent this type of tragedy
they are undertaking immensely difficult
work and we should all be extremely
grateful to them
Mr Speaker these are the days that we
dread
crossing the channel
in unseaworthy vessels is a lethally
dangerous endeavor
it's reason above all that we are
working so hard to destroy the business
model of the people Smugglers evil
organized criminals who treat human
beings as cargo
as the Prime Minister told the house
only yesterday
it is not cruel or unkind to want to
break the Stranglehold of the criminal
gangs who trade in human misery and who
exploit our system and our laws
he was right
this morning's tragedy
like the loss of 27 people on One
November Day last year
is the most sobering reminder possible
of why we have to end these Crossings
we recently agreed the largest ever
small boats deal with France with more
boots on the ground patrolling their
beaches UK and French officers working
together in both countries
the Calais group of northern European
nations Works to disrupt trafficking and
smuggling all along the migration route
and has set an ambition for a UK eu-wide
agreement on migration
and since 2015 we have welcomed 450
000 people here from all across the
world via safe and legal routes making
these dangerous Crossings totally
unnecessary
but it was evident
that we had to go much further which is
why the Prime Minister announced a new
package yesterday
it includes a new permanent unified
small boats operational command bringing
together the military civilian
capabilities and the National Crime
agency
it will coordinate intelligence
interception processing and enforcement
using advanced technology including
drones
we are adding
more than 700 new staff and doubling the
funding for the NCAA to tackle organized
immigration crime in Europe
the Prime Minister announced yesterday a
new agreement with Albania
for the first time border Force officers
will be embedded in Tirana airport
helping to disrupt organized crime
groups and people Smugglers risking
people's lives unnecessarily
and early next year we will introduce
new legislation to make it unambiguously
clear that if some that if someone comes
to the UK illegally they should not be
able to remain here
instead they can expect to be detained
and swiftly returned either to their
home country or to a safe country where
they claim where they claim for Asylum
will be considered
late or spurious claims and appeals will
not be possible and once someone has
been removed they will have no right to
re-entry settlement or citizenship
this will act as a deterrent and it will
save lives
as we grip illegal migration we will
create more safe and legal routes
working with the unhcr to identify those
most in need and introducing an annual
quota set by Parliament
who will work closely with local
authorities to determine capacity
Mr Speaker
it isn't true that our capacity is
Limitless
we are already spending Millions on
hotels every day
people do not need to seek Asylum if
they are already in a safe country
it is vital literally vital that we end
the illegal Crossings in the channel
and I commend the statement to the house
shutter Home Secretary of that Cooper
thank you Mr Speaker and to thank the
Home Secretary for advanced site of her
statement
this is truly tragic deeply distressing
news and all of our thoughts and prayers
will be though with those who have lost
their lives and their families and
friends who have lost loved ones in the
icy waters of the channel
we will think they're thinking too of
those who will be receiving support and
medical assistance who may have been
rescued as well
and all of us will give our thanks to
the brave responders and Rescuers in the
Border force in the rnli and the Coast
Guard in the mod in our emergency
services and in the French authorities
responding not just today to this awful
awful tragedy but also who do such
heroic work every single day it is only
because of their Brave work that more
lives have not been lost
it was barely more than a year ago that
27 lives were lost when a boat went down
and all of us have warned all of us have
feared that it was just a matter of time
before more lives were lost it is of
course why the UK and France both need
to act to stop these dangerous Boat
Crossings
the brutal truth as well is that
criminal gangs have made money from
those lives that were lost today
they have profited as people have
drowned
day after day week after week criminal
gangs are putting lives at risk for
money
and the other brutal truth is that
far from stopping those criminal gangs
those gangs have grown and grown
and the UK and French governments and
authorities have failed to stop the
criminal and Smuggler and trafficking
gangs proliferating around the channel
those gangs have created a multi-million
pound criminal industry with lives at
stake and the action against those gangs
has been too weak
there have been barely any prosecutions
or convictions and barely any inroads
Into The Smuggler of gangs just three
convictions for people smuggling a month
at a time when tens of thousands of
lives are being put at risk each month
it is why we have long called for a long
time for a major boost to the National
Crime agency because we do need major
action and yesterday the Prime Minister
announced an increase for the National
Crime agency I am glad that he has made
some progress on this but can the Home
Secretary clarify what does it mean in
practice how much additional funding
will there be in practice for the
National Crime agency how much and for
specifically for the action on The
Smuggler gangs how many additional
full-time staff will there be and what
is the sense of scale on this because I
fear still that this is too low and this
is too little given the scale of the
problem we Face yesterday the Prime
Minister announced a small boat
operational command again how different
is that to the previous clandestine
Channel threat command led by Commander
Dan Omani which has been in operation
for some time will it still be led by
Commander Dan Omani or by somebody else
will it be the home office or the mod in
charge is it correct that the Navy has
been told they will be standing down on
the 31st of January can she update us
too on the French patrols and
surveillance has the 40 percent promised
increase in patrols started yet and when
will it was this boat picked up as a
result of increased surveillance if it
wasn't what was the reason for that the
Home Secretary has also referred two
safe legal routes she was pressed at the
select committee on a lack of safe legal
routes for children trying to unite with
family in the UK when will she be taking
action to address that to prevent
children seeking to rejoin family in the
UK making desperate Journeys and she
referred to to the prime minister's
statement yesterday can she clarify we
have also called for the fast track for
safe countries and for the backlog to be
cleared the home the Prime Minister said
the set he had set a personal Target of
117 000 cases to be cleared by the end
of next year number 10 later said that
Target was 92 000 could she again
confirm which of those it is
the responsibility for the lives that
have been lost in the channel lies with
the criminal gangs they need to be
caught they need to be prosecuted they
need to be jailed for the loss of life
in the cold sea and we need
comprehensive action we gathered in this
house just over a year ago to lament the
loss of 27 lives none of us want to do
so again none of us want to be here
again that's where we need action before
more lives are lost in Peril on the sea
yeah
thank you Mr Speaker
well today is a day to demonstrate our
Sympathy for the victims and the
families of this deadly and tragic
incident it is a day to Express
gratitude to our hard-working Emergency
Services border force and search and
rescue and mod colleagues who at this
moment are conducting an operation in
the channel in very difficult and
challenging circumstances
The Honorable late my Ryan Mulaney
mentions a few points and I want to
respond to some of those in detail the
small boat's operational command is uh
going to be a new operational command
that the Prime Minister announced
yesterday as part of our plan to go
further on the action that we will take
to stop the boats crossing the channel
this means that we are setting up a new
HQ the small boats operation command in
Border Force to bring our Channel and
processing operation under a single home
office command with military support for
specialist planning and operational
advice as part of this we will bring in
new air and Maritime capabilities
including new drones land-based radar
fixed-wing aircraft and more and we will
be more than doubling our current
permanent Staffing levels with a hundred
new staff at HQ and over 600 new
operational staff based at Dover
that's a sign that we are strengthening
our resolve we are strengthening our
will and we are strengthening our
efforts to do whatever it takes as the
Prime Minister has pledged to stop the
boats crossing the channel it will
improve our intelligence and information
sharing with the French it will improve
and build on the cooperation that we
have with Partners in France
the deal that we signed last month with
colleagues in France is a big step
forward in our cross-channel cooperation
for we share a common Challenge and that
new Arrangement has uh we'll see more
dangerous and unnecessary Crossings
being prevented last year our joint
efforts uh prevented over 23 000
unnecessary Journeys to date this year
that number is 31 000.
that in itself is insufficient but it's
a step in the right direction and the
agreement that we have struck afresh
with the French will go further to
enhance our joint working
she mentions safe and legal roots since
2015 we have made it possible for 450
000 people to come here via safe and
legal routes that's a record of which I
am immensely proud those are people who
have come from countries like Ukraine
from Syria from Afghanistan
there are people who have come from all
over the world directly from places of
danger including via the UK resettlement
scheme where people have been selected
by the UN Refugee agencies from
countries including Ethiopia Iraq Sudan
Eritrea Somalia South Sudan and Yemen
and though and so we will extend safe
and legal Roots once we have dealt with
the appalling people smuggling gangs
risking people's lives as we have seen
this morning
and lastly
that she talks about our track record on
this issue this government won't stop
until we have seen progress until people
understand that taking this lethal
journey is not safe it is not lawful and
it will not lead them to a better life
in the United Kingdom our capacity that
there are there are millions millions of
people around the world who are fleeing
conflict and poverty and who seek a
better life elsewhere our capacity in
this country is not
are infinite we cannot accept everybody
who wishes to come to this country that
is a reality of the world and it's a
reality of Life the other party would
suggest otherwise I hope that she will
join us in our strengthened resolve to
stop this problem by supporting our
measures and supporting our legislation
next year
thank you Mr Speaker I Echo the
sympathies of the Home Secretary and the
tributes to the Rescue Services and
frankly it is a miracle that no lives
have been lost in British territory
waters before now and that's a tribute
to the professionalism of Border force
of the in Ally and Coast Guard and
others and being no doubt the blood is
on the hands of the criminal gangs
responsible for this uh tragedy of
course the best thing would be for those
boats not to leave the shore in the
first place so can she update the house
about any progress she may be having in
discussions with their French
counterparts which will persuade them
either to intercept the those boats if
they get into the water and bring the
passengers back to French land from
where they started or when they do
intercept people on the beaches about to
get into the boats that they are
arrested and detained rather than set
free and allowed to try again the
following night that is the only thing
that is really going to stop this
immediately as we need it to happen
my right honorable friend is right and
I'm very proud of the new agreement that
we have struck with our French
colleagues in in this regard and already
there has been progress in the last few
weeks there have been initial
deployments of embedded offices under
the deal with the First full deployments
before Christmas The Joint headquarters
function is up and running with regular
operational planning meetings between
the UK and French law enforcement and
intelligence agencies and we are working
together with French Partners to achieve
the Calais group agreements that we
struck last week to deepen our
intelligence cooperation with near
Neighbors